depuis 2015 les habitants de maurepas
trouvent porte close au centre nautique
une décision prise par le conseil
municipal et le maire de la ville
grégory gare et astier pour des raisons
de sécurité l'équipe a fait le choix de
détruire la piscine pour construire un
nouvel établissement intercommunal avec
elancourt et coignières géré par un
concessionnaire privé mais l'opposition
de gauche n'approuve pas ce projet dans
notre vision des choses la piste d'une
piscine à maurepas est un service public
est un service public doit être géré par
un organisme public
au lieu de dépenser des millions d'euros
à déconstruire et reconstruire
soyons intelligents réhabilitons la
piscine et faisant gagner de l'argent
omar patients de manière intelligente
dans une conjoncture budgétaire qui est
très difficile selon la mairie la
construction devrait coûter aux
alentours de 13 millions d'euros
les conseillers de l'opposition estime
le double ils ont donc décidé de déposer
un recours contre cette délibération au
tribunal administratif de versailles
les arguments qui ont été présentés aux
trois conseils municipaux pour
s'orienter vers une concession sont
fallacieux on va dire incomplet même
fallacieux puisqu'il ya un certain
nombre d'arguments côté avancé qui
induisent les conseils municipaux en
erreur
on demande au juge administratif d'alors
qu'on n'ait pas entendu sur place
on demande au juge administratif une
vérification de la légalité de
conformité à la réglementation à la loi
des délibérations prises résultats
attendus dans les prochains mois le
bâtiment actuel qui doit être détruit en
2019 est encore en sursis